rushing to the scene of the crash on
Wednesday night but finding only
wreckage and no survivors nine service
members killed during what was supposed
to be a routine training Mission this
was a training progression and
specifically they were flying a
multi-ship formation two ships under
night vision goggles at night
the two Blackhawks crashed after
Witnesses say they were flying unusually
low to the trees two helicopters just
disappeared out of the sky and there's a
large Splash and we ran outside and we
started seeing
um another helicopter that circled that
area where I thought the impact was for
probably 30 minutes and then we saw
ambulances uh and Sir the US military
says these helicopters are equipped with
a kind of black box so they are hopeful
that they will soon know what led to the
crash according to Pentagon statistics
the Army loses an average of five
soldiers every year to Aviation
accidents the Pentagon says it is too
early to tell if this signals a bigger
problem with the Blackhawk
we need to allow time for this
investigation but for example anytime
there is the potential for a fleet of
aircraft uh to have some type of
systemic issue then certainly again
those fleets can be stood down you've
seen us do that with other types of
aircraft in the past
um again I'm not aware of anything like
that right now for the Blackhawk we need
to allow time for the investigation to
run its course the Army now trying to
figure out how a routine training flight
turned deadly for nine of their own
paddickle Hayne Al Jazeera Washington